I guess I would still favor Poirier I do
worry about the damage that he's accrued
over the years and what that might do to
him
but I don't know he uh you know he's
amazing too uh he is a remarkable
fighter and I think he's just got you
know I don't know if he's the best boxer
in the UFC whatever that means but I put
him on the short list yeah I put him on
the short list for sure he's tremendous
so I probably lean Poirier but it's
shush
Mr Luke Thomas the best in the business
man you know I have to send out that
Luke Thomas bat signal because on
Showtime uh my brother from different
mother you're you're I think are you
working the uh Spence Crawford fight in
some capacity like a pre-show or yeah
yeah yeah so I would have been out there
uh starting on Wednesday but I actually
lucked into a situation where
my contract is weird for folks who may
not know so
um I am technically an employee of CBS
but Showtime produces the podcast that
I'm on right
so there's these two and they both owned
by Paramount so they kind of work
together to make it all kind of go but
sometimes I do stuff exclusively for CBS
so out of nowhere uh CBS invited the
podcast to go to Stanford Connecticut on
Thursday and from let me see if I can
get this right on Thursday from 10 a.m
to noon we're going to do a live
Spence Crawford two-hour preview
um on CBS Sports so then that is over at
noon I got a bird to take from there to
Vegas that night then Friday I'll do
weigh-ins and then Saturday I'll do uh
the prelims I'll call the prelims yeah
oh sick brother congrats man I yeah I
saw that that's big and then uh so it's
it's going to be born in combat that
you're flying out for tomorrow when you
guys do the two hour long thing in
Connecticut yeah just morning morning
combat only for CBS Sports and then I'm
flying out separately yeah and that
makes sense I'm surprised I haven't had
you guys work more I mean this is such a
massive fight but because your your
co-host Brian Campbell his background's
boxing right like he knows yeah it's a
[__] and then you know yes all
of it but Brian Campbell specializes in
boxing so he's a good one to have
yeah well actually it'll work out the
opposite so uh he has some kind of uh
issue where he he can work but he can't
go to Vegas so it was actually going to
end up happening as for morning combat
we're going to have two post fight shows
on Saturday night one for Spence
Crawford one for UFC 291 and then he'll
host the UFC 291 one because I won't be
able to watch it obviously and then I'm
gonna do the Spence Crawford one but you
know what the thing is like I've been
covering I covered boxing for a while
back in the day and then uh things
changed when my last on my last job when
I was at MMA fighting through VOX media
um when MMA fighting came aboard I had
to stop doing a lot of boxing coverage I
covered Mayweather Pacquiao for them I
covered Mayweather Canelo oh wow I
covered Lamont Peterson versus Amir Khan
I mean I used to cover boxing fairly
regularly had to get away with it got
got back into it the last four years so
at this point I feel a little bit more
confident you know to do a post-fight
show but uh you know it is a strange
time as opposed to bring to divvy it up
that way yeah you boys are working
though it's a lot of work we had a lot
of shows a lot of content but it's a
good business to be in especially the
fight business right now because like
you said Saturday you have UFC 291 which
is a big dog which we'll talk about but
I I feel like in just maybe it's the
group of guys I'm around the I'm in
Calabasas California maybe it's that I
feel like there should be more hype for
Spence Crawford man like this is a fight
the boxing fans have been waiting for
for how long and now Showtime made it
happen shout out to show time it's
coming to fruition here you're talking
about you know two undefeated Fighters
one guy 28 no what's the other guy 39-0
it's insane yeah it's nuts yeah but I
just feel I mean I and I and I I asked
my team this and maybe I should fire him
I don't know but I go are you guys are
you guys more likely to buy are you more
excited for it this can make you throw
up I said are you more excited for uh
Spence and Crawford or Nate Diaz and
Jake Paul and they're like if we have to
pick one we're going Nate Diaz Jake Paul
I said get out really this is a [__] wow
but yeah but that I feel like there's
you know I don't know like what what
sells more pay-per-views
um that's a good question do we know the
Pay-Per-View price point for the Diaz
fight yet do we know that is it 49.99
I might be I honestly don't know I mean
if there's a because you got you gotta
imagine they're gonna probably charge
I'm gonna I don't know this I'm gonna
guess upwards of 70 or 80. for Spence
Crawford again I haven't don't don't
don't quote me on that but probably I'm
assuming that yeah the HD and
so I don't know so if there's a
substantial difference in pay-per-view
that will obviously affect bias I mean
here's what I'll say right like Showtime
is kind of coming off of not that people
are making direct comparisons but we're
kind of coming off of not too long ago
the tank Davis and Ryan Garcia fight
which was [__] huge right I mean that
was a monster fight right and I know you
know Ryan personally and everything
so so it can't compare to that tank is
one of the biggest stars in boxing just
on pure star terms Ryan Garcia one of
the biggest stars in boxing on just pure
star terms Spence and Crawford aren't
that and so it won't be that but I still
think it will do I mean here's my sort
of official guess I'm gonna guess
between 5 to 750k pay-per-view buys I
agree with that which is still very good
yeah still very good I think Diaz will
probably do somewhere around that maybe
slightly less but still probably pretty
good as well Jake Paul I understand I
understand go ahead sorry I don't
interrupt you that's that's me just just
to wrap up I think I don't know it's
okay just to wrap up I just feel like
um you're right like it's not Garcia and
tank but it I think in the I think by
the time Friday and then Saturday gets
here the buzz is really going to build
and when you think about it I mean don't
you're wrong tank Davis is must see TV
he's the best knockout artists in boxing
right now and his whole kind of persona
out there is insane so you know he
brings a heavy so is Ryan Garcia when
you're talking about straight up boxing
like as far as Talent goes I mean this
is the best fight we've seen in I don't
know how long between these two between
Spence and Crawford I mean oh talent
wise I this one for the ages
this is uh man I struggle to think about
what the most I mean people compare it
because of of the relevancy it had in
terms of determining you know
generational Talent as well as you know
the best fighter of that moment to
Mayweather Pacquiao no it's not going to
do Mayweather Pacquiao numbers I
I don't you know obviously that's not
really in the in the in the cards but in
terms of like what it means for the
sport it's pretty close in the sense
again the celebrity and the the size of
the fight notwithstanding just the
actual boxing terms is to decide
basically the power to pound best guy in
the sport and you talk about it I did a
I did a one hour breakdown on all of
Errol Spence's game you can check that
out at youtube.com morning combat for
folks who haven't saw it and dude like I
thanks man I I break down a lot of film
and you know I'm always honored to break
down please you know I want to be clear
about this like it's always an honor to
watch professionals do something and be
like wow you learn so much dude it was a
treat to watch Spence's game up close I
couldn't believe some of the [__] he's
able to pull off he is he is just he
know what he is meant he's a [__]
Terminator yep he's a Terminator he just
clubs these guys to to into submission
and then on the other side you have Bud
Crawford who is I don't think this is in
any way an exaggeration people can take
issue with it if they want I think a
boxing genius yep I think one of the
highest fight IQs I've ever seen and
those two hammers are gonna meet people
have said by the way Brendan they've
said things like oh was the fight going
to be boring first few rounds you might
not have like the most dynamic action
but the entire Errol Spence game is
built on pressure volume and just
absolutely
beating guys down into not literal
submission but something approximating
it and while Bud's game is all about
courting danger to get just the right
shot by the end of that fight I suspect
it's going to be on fire yeah I I can't
wait I was I was looking uh before we we
spoke I was looking just like what are
the experts kind of the guys who were
have been in the game for a long time
who are they siding with I'd say the
majority of them are signed with uh Bud
Crawford
mm-hmm yes that's what I've seen as well
I mean listen I under I kind of get that
right like
bud has a little bit more magic to his
game you know what I mean he's got a
little bit more of that spell binding
ability to just find the right shot and
the right combination he's a devastating
finisher and remember he was already
Undisputed in another weight class this
is the second wake class Jesus where
he's tried to become Undisputed I think
the thing that people Miss at least as
far as I'm concerned is that I think
Spence well for sure Spence has a better
resume in this weight class at 147
pounds and you could probably argue a
better resume overall in terms of who
he's fought that one's a little bit more
debatable but you know I just don't
there isn't the same kind of Dazzle to
what Spence does and I don't know that
that's affecting how people view the
fight but I kind of feel like it might
be
I feel like too and it's a shame I feel
like a lot of it is because you know
I've had I I've either had both of them
on food truck when I was at Showtime or
just bud but they're not
they're the two best boxers on the
planet but when it comes to
entertainment value like your tick tocks
your Instagram you know like Bud he's
just very dry and all he cares about is
boxing like he's a nicest guy in the
world but you know he's not gonna you
know you're not gonna get any great
sound bites from the press conference
you know yeah I'm gonna beat him up I'm
knock this guy out but you're not
getting a Conor McGregor or a you know
even a a Garcia Ryan Garcia Take there
it's just not what they do unfortunately
the public puts so much into that like
you're missing it though if you want the
two best boxers on the planet that are
finally fighting and you know it'd be an
easy argument Terence Crawford Earl
Spence is a better fight than Manny
Pacquiao and Floyd Mayweather when they
thought they were oh yeah it's not even
close you idiots so with with spent yeah
this is me real deal man
yeah I mean you could argue that you
know the fight between Spencer Crawford
should have happened a little bit
earlier and I don't think that that's in
any way unfair but you know you're not
like you know Manny I remember Manny
after the Pacquiao excuse me Manny after
the Mayweather fight was like oh my
shoulder was all jacked down and then
fans tried to sue him and all that [__]
dude you just you're you're not gonna
get that with these two it's just not
gonna be that way
um again one guy might be way better
than the other one some of the rounds
might be uh hard to call early I don't
know about that part but in terms of
getting guys a little bit closer or in
the case of Spence I would argue right
smack in the middle of his prime
um or you know I would say the the pro
this is probably the end of his prime
but I think he's still in it uh it's
just radically different radically
different than that I have significantly
higher hopes as well me too I can't wait
I can't wait yeah I wanted to talk to
you about it because no one around here
really knows boxing so it's it's an
exciting one so you have that but but
isn't it funny like because everyone's
like oh you know what I hate about
boxing is the best don't fight the best
it's like well yeah here you go you know
boys I gotta tell you yeah uh if you
want the best fight and the best I have
great news for you yes
buy it this is what you guys complain
about they said that's the problem with
box my UFC is doing well you know you'll
be at the fight work in the fight but
you know you're missing a pretty damn
good UFC 291 that card's pretty stacked
dude that card
really I say I I I was saying this too I
was saying this too so check this out so
I mean I don't know when this is going
to air but at the time of Thursday okay
by the time of you and I recording this
tomorrow is uh in a way in Fulton which
is going to be that's more of a boxing
hard course but it's still an extremely
relevant fight in boxing then of course
on uh Saturday you've got 291 sick you
got Spence Crawford you've even got a
little bit of Bellator versus ryzen
which has a couple of good bangers on
that one as well I'm just sort of
pointing out whatever your crown jewel
is whether it's the MMA side or whether
it's the boxing side dude what a week
what a weekend for Combat Sports huh
you've got one of the you've got
everything BMF for you know whatever
people whatever value people want to
ascribe to the Belt you know if you had
to pick two BMF candidates them two
would be at the top of the list yep then
you got Spence Crawford on the side too
this is our cup truly runneth over with
this you know yeah for our gig it's a
great deal but really if you look at the
whole year like there's a lot of cool
stuff happening man in the fight game
like you got Francis Fury got announced
you know Jon Jones Steve a coming up
like there's a lot of cool stuff
happening man
what's your what's your uh temperature
so to speak on Francis and uh fiori
um I was one of the guys I'm close with
France's agent Markel I'm close with him
so I talked to him pretty frequently
about it when the pfl deal got announced
I think people are missing the point
because when that pfl deal got announced
I went okay well for him to leave the
UFC they have to know that the fury
fight can happen because if he left the
UFC just signed with pfl terrible idea
even though the pfl you know they
they're giving them all that guaranteed
you know money and half the gate and the
paper it's nuts that business model is
not going to work there's there's no way
so that can't be the move I said the
only way that it worked out for for
France is is if he gets that big Marquee
fight with Fury or Joshua Wilder that
doesn't happen he made a mistake and
everyone just you know was hounding
Francis making fun of him saying
horrible who's he gonna fight and all
that stuff in pfl I don't care about pfl
it's not about the pfl his [__] you
money comes from fighting Fury and he
made it took some time but he made it
happen so no matter if he gets knocked
down in the first second or first round
doesn't matter he what he did is unheard
of it's a win for Francis so it's a huge
win for Francis and it's also I talked
about my show it's like be careful
because you know Dana White the UFC they
didn't want this fight to happen they
don't like when guys go out and do these
things also you know the the other
matchmakers in boxing didn't want this
fight to happen they want fear to fight
usick so there's gonna be a lot of
news coming out fake news you know for
lack of better term a lot of fake news
at first it was he's only making eight
million dollars that's not true then it
was it's an exhibition fight it's not
real that's not true it's 10 Rounds you
know so it's like they're trying to like
put a wet blanket on this thing it's
just not working so I think he just
shows you that Francis is a threat I
think you made the right choice and no
matter what he's going to walk away from
this way way richer which was the which
was the plan I don't care what happened
to pfl that's a side note I don't care
yeah dude like I mean I mean I don't
think this is likely I'm not saying that
I uh expect this but you couldn't
like rule it out and what I mean is my
guess is he Francis will probably pull
somewhere between when it's all said and
done but between like 30 and 40 million
but that could go higher right so let's
just say it's I don't know 50 60 million
maybe even 75 million that seems a
little excessive but you know you get
the idea do you even need to fight after
that you know what I mean like that
that's what it's icing on the cake ton
of money yeah dude and it's like and
then you know people are like oh he
could have fought John that for the most
money in the heavyweight division of all
time it's like okay did they offer him
40 million though he's won right like he
made the right choice who's he gonna
find pfl who gives a [__] some poor
sucker is getting knocked out that we're
not gonna watch but he's won as far as
boxing goes that's all that that was his
whole point man he's done it yeah he'll
he'll he'll make more in that one fight
than uh not only from that last contract
they offered but that contract plus
every other contract he had in MMA so
correct you know uh he gets the last he
assuming it all goes through he will
have the last left but it was funny just
to just to like bring It full circle Bud
Crawford I guess did his open workout at
like the UFC Pi I think or something
like that maybe the Apex or whatever
something like that uh some UFC facility
and uh so he was doing media day there
for himself and uh and one of the
reporters like hey what chance I think
was the MMA reporter like what chance do
you give Francis he was like zero
[__] zero he didn't yeah he was like
he didn't even say like point one no
zero feels like but but I will see yeah
he's right but I will say this and again
I don't care about any of that France is
getting paid if he gets slobber knocked
in a second he still made the right
choice but I will say this and you know
that's how I got in with Showtime I I
was the the MMA expert for Connor first
Floyd so I had to sell people on Connor
beating Floyd with you know it's a paid
gay I tried my best man it was a tough
one but
Francis has more of a chance to win than
Connor does because Francis has that one
knockout one shot knockout power like if
I don't give a [__] if you're Tyson Fury
Aleister Overeem you know Mark hunt I
don't care Roy Nelson I don't care who
you are if Francis lands with four ounce
gloves or 10 ounce gloves on that
fight's over dude so he there he has a
better shot to land that than Conor does
beating Floyd Mayweather that's all I'm
saying yeah yeah neither One's Gonna Win
but I'm just saying right yeah I mean I
wouldn't I wouldn't bet against Fury
either but
um you know the interesting part was
like I remember you know Paulie
monologue you know Paulie too I like
Paulie a lot actually I love that MMA
yeah people never May kind of get down
on him but um yeah he he uh you know
because this thing with Connor just it
didn't really go all that well for him
but like one thing he was really right
about was like his power doesn't
translate to boxing that we've only had
the one fight so you know would it be
different in another one I don't know
but it didn't translate that night for
sure I have a feeling francis's power
will translate but um I guess we will
see uh what was it October 28th October
now let me ask you this that's two weeks
before Jon Jones steep a mass Square
Garden what sells more pay-per-views I'm
asking again what sells more
pay-per-views Francis Fury or Stephen
Jon Jones Matt Square Garden that card
can be loaded but I just feel like
Francis and and fury they sell more pay
views when it reaches out Beyond just
our fight base
it's a great question also you know
what's kind of funny you know Dana White
has to hate the fact that uh
Fury and ganu is going to be on ESPN
plus pay-per-view so you know they're
the the pay-per-view provider and of
course they're probably all too happy to
collect those checks hell yeah but um to
answer the question it's okay so working
against Fury and ganu is less so UFC but
more that it's going to be in the
afternoon in all likelihood right
because if it's going to be in Saudi
Arabia they're just gonna have to time
it in a way where it's just going to be
you know middle to late afternoon on the
East Coast or even earlier for you guys
out there on the west coast so that will
hurt it but like star attraction versus
Star attraction as I do think the Jones
cpify will do well please don't
misunderstand me
but I think Fury and ganu is a listen
here's the thing I always try to explain
to not so much to you because you know
this but like to to to to hardcore MMA
fans it's like the biggest section of
not just hardcore MMA fans excuse me the
biggest section of MMA fandom and the
biggest section of boxing fandom are the
people who know the least about it right
it's the the Casual fans like you're
pulling in people who know [__] all
about anything other than I know that
guy's name he's big and powerful I know
that guy's name he's whatever and they
just want to see that Collide this is
why I like Spence Crawford has a little
bit more of an uphill climb relative to
that in that sense so Jones is a big
star Stipe obviously I think with that
with in that matchup will compliment him
nicely for uh top of the Marquee but
Fury and ganu together that's just much
more star power packed in I think but
yeah it's we're talking about as far as
the a side clearly Furies the a side
when usually at pay-per-view numbers and
you know obviously I think the best
heavyweight of all time but Francis in
theory isn't a pay-per-view star if you
look at his sales on with the UFC that's
why they're willing to let him walk they
went we're good man go ahead his
pay-per-view numbers were never great so
it's weird to expect that to go up here
you know and if you compare Jones
pay-per-views and stipes they Trump
Furies especially Jones so if you're
going based off kind of pay-per-view you
know uh fight science or fight math
Jones and steepe should sell more but I
think this is just such a special
occasion and you're bringing the boxing
world into it too which makes it more
unique that I think it's going to
outsell that UFC with Jones and steepe
could be wrong that's right so no no I
so I think you're onto something let me
clarify so if you're just stacking up
individually star power and where it
gets assigned then Jones does have I
think incredible play not for number one
maybe but certainly for number two
um and he even maybe number one
depending on how you want to look at it
but
um what I would say is the point that
you raised at the end right which is you
get this dude I'm telling you it's the
people who know the least it's the
boxing versus MMA ooh I want to see that
Crowd Oh a knock a tremendous knockout
artist from MMA is going to fight this
big mouth
uh British heavyweight that might be
interesting even though you know most uh
inside observers would be like that's
tough oh that's that's a little climb
for him yeah it doesn't matter it's this
weirdness that galvanizes everything
it's got the it's got more of that like
that pop culture pull than a strict
although very good MMA fight might have
and that's where the money comes from
that pop culture once you get TMZ
reporting on it and you know you got the
guys at Starbucks talking about that's
who buys it and that's when you get make
that [__] you money but I think too
what's interesting is
as just a guy who the fury is my
favorite fighter in Combat Sports I love
Fury I've worked with him he's one of my
favorite people he's a special person
as a like you know I love boxing I do
wish she would have fought using before
this I think that's it like hangs over
his head a little bit in this goes hold
on you're gonna fight this MMA fighter
he's never boxed over defend the battle
against USIC who we think might beat you
he's like yeah I'm gonna do this and
then that I wish he would have reversed
it fought usick earlier this year and
then he was fighting Francis in October
I just think you'd been better boxing
kind of hardcores wouldn't be so upset
if that usick fight wasn't looming out
there if you would have just got that
done I think this would have been even
bigger
so if you talk to people inside boxing
one theory that has been floated to me
is that what he might end up doing is
fighting well he's going to fight
Francis we know that but then after that
it's but it's it's it's it's it's
rumored
that he could turn around quickly
including as early as December late
December like a Christmasy kind of time
and then fight usick then okay so that
is contingent that's contingent upon a
lot of different things going correctly
which we all know in Combat Sports is
not smart to bet on and I think if he
does that not not necessarily in
December but let's say you know first
quarter of 2024 or something yeah I
don't think it'd be yeah exactly I don't
think it'd be the end of the world but I
will say this if he doesn't do that and
in fact he just takes this fight and
then you know whatever does next
I mean how can you say he didn't duck us
how can you say that how can you say he
didn't he he would be literally avoiding
a fight to take another fight and that
fight was for you know the one face one
name that's the guide heavyweight unify
all the titles bang you know and he
avoided that to fight Francis like dude
it's so funny you know like when that
fight got announced on the MMA side
because my feed is now filled with both
Sports on the MMA side there were people
who don't like Francis but there was a
lot of people who were like yeah Francis
go get that bag you know you saw a lot
of people cheering them on and then on
the boxing side it was like yo [__] Fury
who what is he doing this is ridiculous
the boxing fans are mass Fury you know
and I will say this again as a big Fury
fan
that usick fight ain't easy like you
know that one scares me that like
using's a bad man dude like you watch
this fight against Joshua like oh my god
dude this dude is a Savage never lost in
anything never lost he undersized his
technical as a [__] and just a
Ukrainian dog so part of me is like oh
man that's a scary fight for Fury bro
like that ain't easy that's by far his
toughest matchup
oh I don't think there's any question I
mean you know he the fight with Deontay
is tough because Wilder has huge power
but he's not he's overmatched from a
skill standpoint relative to Fury and I
would say you know even if he fought
Joshua Joshua to me
a little bit chinny uh doesn't quite
fight aggressively in the way that he
used to which is understandable given
that he you know lost the Ruiz and
whatnot
um so and then also the Vladimir
Klitschko fight was an amazing fight by
him but you know he got hit a lot in
that contest as well and I think that's
kind of changed his style over time so
that's why I think he likes those fights
and don't get me wrong he is an amazing
amazing talent and like you know the
gusts that he's had at times has been
truly you know you love guys who are
daring you know what I mean that's what
you really love and there was a time
there he was doing that
but usick is a complete I mean a
Cruiserweight who moved up unified all
the tiles at cruises away this is again
like Bud Crawford if he fought Fury that
would be the second weight class he is
trying to become Undisputed which means
for folks who don't know all four belts
in the four bell era and all the all the
ones that matter basically
um at the same time which would be
remarkable and to your point high-fide
IQ uh um fast for a heavyweight
relatively speaking right smart good I
mean just there's just a lot of things
about that that make that a very tough
fight for Fury so this is what I mean
like if you take the Francis fight
because you also wanted the bag and then
you take the six fight I get but if not
it's like dude it's hard to just look at
this and be like yeah you avoided the
tougher challenge for the easier one man
like it is what it is you know yeah I
don't think you'd be as big of a deal if
it wasn't his toughest challenge like
anyone that knows boxing like yeah it's
a tough fight for fury like it's just
not some guy some up-and-comer where
fear is like nah get to it it's like no
he's the guy he's the guy we think that
can beat you and so yeah for Fury's
Legend see he has to do it and he's
going to piss off the boxing fans
forever if he doesn't fight Francis then
fight him shortly after which I think
you will it's not like Fury scared of
him for God's sakes I hate when people
say that
no afraid no but I do think he respects
what yeah to like you know like he knows
that usick is not to be trifled with
different like you have to be on point
you know agree
um let's get some UFC uh 291 here man uh
thoughts on the card or you know it I
think it should be noted it is in Salt
Lake City which is high elevation but
the lighter weights not be the end of
the world for engaging for a Poirier I
don't you know poory's out there gechi
trains at high altitude so they'll be
okay
Derek Lewis is [__] and I think UFC
did on purpose they're like hey dude you
know damn well you can't go in the
second and third at elevation you get
one round of Fury let's get this guy out
of here so I think that was
intentionally done like you got to go
you know damn well you can't get to the
second third round
dude you know I I might be
misremembering this but I don't think so
and I want to be clear like any time you
see any I was in the back for I think it
was
I I want to say I could be getting this
wrong but I think this is right I was in
the back for UFC 135 that's Jones versus
Rampage that was at the Pepsi Center
Denver Colorado right uh you know that
well I'm sure
and I remember being back there and
seeing I believe Mark hunt versus Ben
Rothwell yes that card yep
yeah
and I remember being backstage now you
gotta understand I think that fight went
the distance or something pretty close
to it you know you see yeah so you see
guys come back from a three-round UFC
fight yeah they're going to be a little
[__] up but I remember watching Mark
hunt and I'm not kidding it must have
been like 20 minutes no that's not quite
that long because after he went to the
triage place he went back to his thing
but there was a there was a while there
where I watched him and it looked like
he could not get enough air like he just
kept like
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly like just
gulping it uh you remember Dana wasn't
as bad no matter Dana goes we will we
will after that fight at the Press
crimes goes yes we will never put
another heavyweight fight in Denver high
elevation ever again and then shortly
after that yeah get you know Kane and uh
verdum and or was it Kanan for Doom in
Mexico which is even higher Mexico City
which is which is even higher elevation
yes nuts yeah dude it's a man people
like if you know you know this really
well but like if you've never been an
elevation and again for a high level for
a high level athlete like to your point
um gaichi who's accustomed to it but
even then a guy who's at sea level most
of the time like Poirier I think he'll
be just fine when it's all said and done
I mean these are guys an incredible
cardiovascular condition they'll be okay
but dude you know if you if for folks
who've never been in elevation dude it
will [__] you up and it takes a long
time to really get used to it like dude
I'll tell you a story and this is not
the same thing and I'm not a high level
I'm not an athlete in any capacity but
for example where my wife is from she's
from a place in South America that has
even higher elevation than Mexico City
it's about another thousand so Denver's
about 5 000 give or take Mexico cities I
think it's about like 70 7200 7 500 and
then uh where my wife's from Bogota
Colombia it's at 83 or 84. God damn
right dude yeah dude
you get up that high and it'll mess with
you a little bit you for example you
can't get sleep it will throw off your
sleep schedule
um the high altitude at times will
completely reduce your appetite you have
no desire to eat whatsoever so you're
not sleeping necessarily you're not
eating you remember like verdum went to
Mexico City when he fought cane well in
advance Kane was like yeah I'll show up
the week of dude week of at 7 500 feet
is unacceptable you will not be your
body absolutely will not be ready for it
so I hope I don't know what Derek Lewis
has been doing I don't know if he did
she's been there a little while yeah I
think UFC's like hey dude this elevation
you got one round to get this done I
think you get to get it done against uh
delima there uh are you excited for the
bmfl title what's your temperature on
this are you one of those guys that
can't wait to see it
I mean I don't really here's the thing I
how do I explain this it doesn't do
anything for me or against me you know
like I'm with you that it's there and I
also want to say this like if the
individual athlete takes pride in it
then I kind of have pride for them a
little uh but if they don't then I
understand that too I mean what does the
title really mean you know I don't know
it I don't know what it means I guess
everyone can decide here's what I can
say these are two a-level fighters they
are still on the right side of 35. it's
folks forget this
Poirier was gaichi's third UFC fight
third UFC fight he is a significantly
different guy this time although of
course so was Dustin Poirier so for me
it's like there's so much quality and
story in the fight that they wanted to
put a belt on it of dubious value or
significance or even meaning then I
understand that I I understand and
accept that I just I can't get on here
and be like oh my God I can't wait to
see it it's like yeah it's cool it's
cool I I don't want to be you know what
I mean I don't want to be some hater on
it I'm not like it's so terrible it's
fine yeah that's where I'm at with it
it's fine I think for me too with the
bmfl title I think I'd be more excited
for them if it changed their pay
structure too does that make sense so if
you become a legit Champion your pay
structure is significantly different
than if you're just a contender if that
title winning the BMF they went yeah
you're getting the same you know kind of
pay that you would get if you were an
actual champion that's like damn this
actually means something doesn't mean
too much I mean for the fans it means a
little something so I'm like all right
whatever I'm excited for the fight I
feel the same way about this as the way
I do about Mark Chev and Charles Olivera
too what okay
even though that's for an actual title
yeah I'm not hating any facet they're
two of the very best
we just saw that fight we I just [__]
saw machev destroy Charles I just saw it
and then they run it back and it's not
like a two-year three-year layoff where
Charles Oliver has been in the lab and
he's had he's gotten better his
confidence is different he got one good
win
and then they run it back it's like okay
now I don't know what else they would do
at 55 so it makes sense but like Macho
jump into 170 what's interesting him
against volkanovsky was fun but this I
just went all right I've seen it I don't
think Charles beats him so it's like all
right
well I'm I would say I don't think what
you're saying is unfair I would say I'm
in a somewhat different position which
is I don't really I don't really take
issue with the analysis that you have I
think it's actually pretty fair but
there wasn't a big time between the
first and second fights
um to your point they didn't have really
I think they want to do the Volk fight
but it just wasn't gonna wasn't gonna
work and also makachev versus Edwards
it's like
okay I mean these are two good Fighters
but like why the [__] are we doing this
you know what I mean yeah it's no sense
that doesn't really make sense yeah
so but here's what I would say here's
what I would say
I have a lot of respect for banil Darius
uh I have a lot of respect for his game
I have a lot you know he lost against
Charles fair and square but for Charles
Charles to beat him the way he did was
like amazing and we know Charles is
capable of being both amazing and then
being at times you know fallen short but
what I mean to say is there was a couple
of things he did differently in that
fight that told me he learned his lesson
like he used to always do a jumping spin
kick to close distance and a lot of guys
would block it and you know he would use
it to close distance or back him up
against the fence and he didn't do that
at all this time because when he tried
to do that [__] against makachev he just
got out of the way it didn't go for him
yeah and he kind of was confused so it's
like he was eliminating pieces of his
game that were flashy but stupid or just
real at a bare minimum just not valuable
and you know to your point do I favor
Islam a second time yes yes I do I think
Islam is inherently a bad matchup for
him but uh I have more hope for Charles
I have I have more hope that Charles can
turn in A Better Effort this time and
for that reason and to your point there
being nothing else really uh available
yeah I'm I'm actually looking forward to
it all right I I mean I get it I I wish
I was more excited about it I'm more
excited about Jan and Alex Pierre
because there's like this mystery there
yes and that's the co-main event and I
just feel like my so my head's going
John's bigger dude he has more MMA
fights he can take him down and this
thing pretty easy but my heart's like
dude I hope Alex Pierre wins I hope he
wins because the matchups that light
heavyweight if he's Champion are
fantastic Yuri rakik uh [__] Johnny
Walker there's so many fun matchups but
they gave him the one besides magu
Madoff they gave him the one fight
that's a kind of a disaster form and
yawn I'm like why would you do that
could be there's so many funny quotes
for him you [__] them
it could be too it could be you know
because uh padeta kind of holds his
hands like this you know like he's kind
of out here yep which is why he got
counter from Izzy he popped Izzy and
then just didn't even he didn't bring he
wasn't like this you know he didn't have
his guard high or whatever he just kind
of Pops him and then leaves here this is
gigantic opening so is he stung them for
it it's like dude well if Izzy can do
that at 185 you would imagine that
blahovich could do that at 205 but
here's what I'll say man I and I know he
thought
um
I'll just say this in MMA in MMA I am
very curious to see what potatoes uh
punch resistance looks like at 205. I
mean also I I want to see like what his
build looks like at this point someone
was saying he was walking around at like
2 30 235 something like that uh yeah no
and which is like you know you get
trying to get down to 205 which I'm sure
he'll do but like it's like holy [__]
[__] I mean this guy is huge huge and
the best part is like dude this this
division at the at the top is kind of a
mess with you know Hill got injured I
feel bad for Hill then Yuri had a whole
thing he's coming back you didn't even
mention on Goliath on Goliath's kind of
sitting out there looking for a dance
partner because his fight with yon
sucked the horn or at least it didn't
resolve in uh anything so it's like so
you've got Pereira Yan Uncle I have
rakich coming back walker I mean dude
you know to me it seems like the
division has like what okay does it have
a dominant figure and I think that's
always better to have a dominant figure
than not but but
I'm added a little bit of parody and
some fun matchups if the UFC or the
fights could shake out in a way we can
get those and uh in Clive it's like get
out of here dude if you get out of here
like he's the one guy that's gonna
wrestle all these guys you know I hate
to say it he's a good dude and he's fun
to watch get out of here because if
that's Piera Yuri uh you know you got
[__] Johnny Walker like let them have
their fun and Clive get out of here get
out we gotta have some fun
I feel like ankalaya will strike with
people when they're like a little bit
over match you know yeah you know but
it's like against a dude like like do we
really think he's gonna kick box for
five rounds with Alex perdeda like I
don't really think definitely you know
what I mean now John has John did an
interview in New York Post which is
funny New York Post barely covers UFC
and he was on the front cover there and
he goes I'm gonna strike with him my
plan is to strike with Alex Pierre I'm
like oh this is just this just him
baiting Alex like he thinks he's gonna
strike with him and he's gonna shoot a
double egg and drive him to the cage
faster than anything there's no way he's
that stupid he needs a win and he's also
40. you gotta remember Jan is 40.
is he really is he 40 years away good
Lord he is older than I thought he was
then um
you know what he stood with Izzy for a
little while now Izzy's different is
he's different
um but you know he's not afraid of doing
that but I think you're right like
what if you I mean listen Izzy kind of
got a little [__] when people were when
people got mad at him when he was like
you know I made the path for him when he
was talking about getting to himself I
made the path for potato a little bit
easier because he didn't have to go
through all the wrestlers he just got to
go through a a quick and path he's right
and people had to kind of push back on
that but he was right he was absolutely
right I mean if you're young I mean just
honestly if you're John bolovic and his
team are you really planning to stand
with this [__] cyborg hell no for 20
or for 15 minutes dude [__] that that's
crazy I hope he does but yeah yeah I
mean it'd be great if he wants to but
it's like you know no Force forced to
bet on your mortgage or something it's
like uh yeah I'm gonna bet on a little
bit of ground action if he's I mean if
he has any sense but he and he does I
think that's why I'm more excited for
that fight it's like this like mystery
fight like is Alex at 205 is gonna be
this monster John can't take him down
he's forced strike with me knocks his
head off the light heavyweight division
could use that especially with you know
Jamal Hill being out Yuri's hopefully
coming back and then and there's so many
fun matchups for Alex I'm just I don't
know I'm more excited about that the one
tell me where you're at the temperature
on this Tony Ferguson Bobby green
does Tony Ferguson make you more sad or
does BJ Penn's downfall make you sadder
BJ's is well
um
Jesus it's a tough one right the night
is young
um
first ballot Hall of Famer
dude people just if you missed BJ pens
Prime I don't even know what to tell you
you know like
try I use this word sometimes and maybe
a little bit too much but this was one
guy when I did I remember I remember
after he beat
maybe it was the Shirk fight or maybe it
was the Diego fight I'm not sure which
one maybe it was the Diego fight I
remember thinking like dude there is an
A and of course this was later proven
not true but the way in which he looked
like okay you know this
when BJ Penn was all in in his prime
with the morenovich brothers
dude he was absolutely
terrifying terrifying the best you just
can't even imagine to this point like
you know this is getting a little bit
esoteric uh Craig Jones has talked about
it but like octopus guard is a thing you
see a little bit more now and certainly
in Jiu Jitsu but in MMA but he was doing
octopus guard back takes in the second
Hughes fight this is a long time ago
like people ask like whose game would
translate to today and I think some
things have to be changed around for
just about anybody you pick but if I had
to pick like a guy in his prime to come
and compete and like you know do well do
Prime BJ impossible to take down
impossible to hurt could hard puncher
and Jiu Jitsu like you'd never seen
before yeah dude he is he was a [__]
phenom
and then to go from that to like all the
losses and then that like super weird
run for governor thing after he was
having do you ever pay any attention to
that I paid it I just tuned in to one of
his like
like Town
Hall I couldn't and he went to NASCAR in
in Hawaii he was like he was like we
need NASCAR I'm like this is fantastic
this is like what makes people I know
like what makes people think after a
lifetime of fist fighting that they
would be a good candidate for municipal
governance of an important U.S state
it's insane it's like dude this is not
even it's not even in the same I I you
know it kind of bummed me out to be
honest yeah it kind of bummed me out I
think Ferguson has had yeah go ahead
yeah well I was gonna say Ferguson to me
has had some difficulties yeah um that's
been well known that's been well known
so my only hope is and recently I I know
he pleaded not guilty to uh I believe a
drunken driving charge I could I could
be getting some of that wrong yeah isn't
it um
yeah I hope that um I hope he's got a
family around him and I hope that he can
be happy and
um live a life with them I'll just I
just I don't these are two guys man I
really like I really like Tony Ferguson
you know and I like to BJ Penn it's just
I don't know what the [__] happened to
BJ man but also Tony Ferguson his prime
remember what he won like 12 fights in a
row dude and we were supposed to get
that uh khabib fight some what three
times in a row just wasn't happening and
we didn't know who's the best 155 or
walking the planet you were the Tony
Ferguson guy or khabib guy and then you
you look at his like strength of
schedule I mean my God man he's F he
fought Killers dude even you know he's
had this tough run with the losses but
they're not throwing them easy guys man
they're thrown to the [__] wolves
which I don't get that I don't get it I
I I've never understood that he's just
getting thrown to the [__] Savages
man
yeah Bobby green is um he's no pushover
you know uh I mean here's the thing too
like it was funny to go full circle here
we're talking about elevation and
elevation in Mexico City I think my
favorite
Tony Ferguson win was when he beat
Rafael dos anjos in the [__] sky in
Mexico City like 7 500 whatever it is 7
400 something like that feet in the air
and dude you go if you if you haven't
seen in a while or you don't remember it
or if anyone out there whoever go watch
that fight dude Tony puts a pace on him
and RDA is also another one of these
guys who is he'll fight anybody he's
always prepared he's always in physical
shape could take his talents to 170 and
at least do pretty well up there
um was the belt holder at 155 like we're
not talking about some pushover dude and
Tony put it on him Tony put it on him
without ever losing breath without ever
slowing down nothing just marched
through not through him because RDA was
a sturdy
um put in a sturdy defensive effort but
he was never he was never in that fight
like Tony beat him cleanly and I was
just amazed I was like holy [__] this
one was so good so damn good dude he was
so good in his prime I think that's what
buns out maybe because it's it's fresh
in my memory has run and it kind of he
kind of got screwed over because
remember he was doing a parent's I think
on like UFC Live or whatever and was
walking off stage and blew his knee out
remember that [__] yes he tripped over a
cable yeah I tripped over a cable blew
his knee out so then that the khabib
fight didn't happen then it was just
like the string of bad luck and then it
could be missing weight and we just
never got to see it it was such a shame
and then now here we are talking I think
he's the biggest dog on the card he gets
bobby green
oh my God I haven't seen the odds but
that would be amazing he's a plus 285
Bobby Green's A minus 375. but also you
know I mean at the same time man it's
like dude you know here's the problem
with Tony
okay two problems one in general he
always accepted and courted too much
punishment yep and
dude there's just no denying he was
never the same after that Justin Gates
you fight he was never the same guy he
took a tremendous
beating and remember it went on and
those are the ones that get you right I
remember the first time that I had seen
this in MMA I remember when Rich
Franklin beat David luazo and you know
if you've never seen that dude it's it
the fight just keeps going and keeps
going rich just keeps beating the [__]
out of him dude Lazo was never the same
after that you could change a guy you
can change a guy and uh he did okay she
did and dude you just can't you can't
you can't be in car crashes like that as
often as he was and then just be the
same it doesn't work that way and I
think he paid for it and now we're at
the spot where
you know unfortunately I just don't
exactly know what he has left I I hope
I'm wrong me too I hope you're right I
hope he wins God knows he needs it I
remember that that Tony Ferguson gaichi
fight I remember my co-host Brian Callan
he loves UFC he's not hardcore but he
watches when he can I remember he's like
I'm never watching UFC again
I mean he was like boycotting for like
three days he's like that's it man this
is abuse how does nobody throw in the
towel he's like how can Dana do this I'm
like it's not really up to Dana Brian
like you should be mad at his Corners
corner should be the one still in the in
the towel Dana can't throw in towels
it's not he's like how can he clear him
to fight and I'm like what can you do
man it's it's tough it's tough
people
those Corners don't want to stop fights
Tony would you know would never want
that fight stop remember the ref had to
intervene uh I heard Dean had to
intervene uh but it's like I just keep
trying to warn these guys man you know
it's when you're 28 it's very hard for
an old guy who never fought to look at a
28 year old man and be like dude
preserve your [__] because it like if
you don't if you don't put in more
defense into your style by the time
you're my age or like the amount of uh
quality of life you will be sacrificing
will be extraordinary and even more
readily than that it will it will hasten
your exit in all likelihood and um
he's one he's one of the toughest I mean
we should give him credit like he's one
of the toughest guys I've ever seen but
they're like like all things there's a
limit there's a limit yep well we can't
end on that because now I'm sad but with
uh with Poirier with poorie Justin
gaichi do you see it going different you
know they find 2018
Trevor Whitman and gaichi say after that
fight we've changed I've changed my
style I'm fighting more strategic I'm
fighting smarter I would argue and I you
know I know Trevor really well use my
coach I would argue that
I don't know if he's been fighting
smarter he still fights like a banshee
maybe a little more controlled but I'd
argue that he's fought older guys and
it's worked so we can they can highlight
that and go well look at where one
whatever for our last six or six our
last eight since losing a dozen boy I'd
say strength is schedule there you know
he fought you know Donald Cerrone
Ferguson the older guys on their way out
RDA older guys uh so I think he maybe he
can say he's fighting smarter but when
you look at certain fights like I don't
know man I don't know if it's you know
because he did change his stock he's
still pretty wild you know but then the
physiv kg fight was pretty damn cute he
can be yeah I was just gonna say that so
I was one of these guys who was like
well
maybe father time and all that damage
because listen I mean the first guy who
will tell you that he knows that his
style is gonna you know hasten his exit
and cause problems is just engaged yeah
he has been very very upfront with the
audience and like he is aware of the
cost he is bearing which is unusual most
guys are like somewhat in denial about
it until it's too late you know uh he's
been up front he's like I know that the
style and this again this is even pre
all the changes but still like he was
readily accepting the damage but I tell
you what dude that physique win was
legit big time because physiv was all
over him early and then Justin kind of
stuck it out and stuck it out and stuck
it out and then put it on him late that
ability to Rally that ability to push
through that ability to beat to the
point a younger guy like that was to me
extremely impressive you know your ass
like does he fight differently
I think that I would take something of a
middle ground on this one where I do
believe that you know he is still
hittable in ways that haven't
um I'll just leave it that he is still
he is still hittable but I think he sets
up his offense much more thoughtfully
and I do think his defense has to an
extent gotten better some of the I'm
just gonna do this and walk forward
recklessness he has removed we talk
about like Charles Oliveira right yes
some of the things he's taking he's
taken out some uh not you know has he
completely revolutionized his game well
I don't know about that but he's
definitely taken out the parts that make
him more vulnerable that don't serve his
interests that make him a Target and
then he's better about getting in and
getting out sometimes he'll abandon that
but I do think there is a noteworthy and
important change I think when I look at
the fight and you correct me if I'm
wrong I you know if you look at the 2018
fight gaichu was kind of having his way
with dust Emporia with the light kicks
and a lot of success going to that
fourth round until Dustin pory countered
that leg kick finally and ended the
fight gaichu is winning that fight you
know so I think if you if fighting down
you look from 2018 to where they're at
now Porres gonna know the leg kicks
coming I think Porey uses utilizes his
grappling I think he tries to get gaichi
down he has a much more he's more versed
on the ground he's the legit black belt
you know that's where gaichi has kind of
gaping holes when it comes to the ground
so I'd assume pory is like all right
we're not just gonna sit there and eat
light kicks if he's gonna light kick
we're gonna shoot for some takedowns I
think we see more grappling I don't
think it's gonna be this fight of the
year that everyone's thinking I think
gaichi finishes with submission
oh
um I'm sorry POI finished some
submission yeah
he might I mean folks forget this too
two things that stood out to me from
that first fight one uh gaichi was
deducted a point for eye pokes
inadvertent but yeah it happened twice
so there was what was one I'd be curious
to see if that shows up again probably
not but worth bringing up and then the
second part was it five metric didn't
count it because they have a different
set of rules for what constitutes a
takedown they don't use wrestling rules
they have to be MMA
um components added in but like there
was one moment where uh Poirier was able
to lift gaichi and sit him down uh
almost flat on his back until gaichi was
able to roll and turn and get up point
being is like that I wonder if they
might decide to build on that but the
big part was you you were right like the
leg kicking particularly the inside leg
kicking as poorier moved into position
but then that big left hand the huge
left hand from Poirier dude that thing
is do he can stop any lightweight in the
world if he lands with that one I just I
I feel like one way or the other that
someone's still going to play a role are
you favoriting uh gachio or Poirier in
this do you do picks or no
I try not to I'm not good at them I mean
I have to for for my podcast but here's
my thing your fan the haters would be
like go shop so bad at pigs hey [__]
tell me who's good at it it's MMA I
don't know anybody who's crushing it
like this that's why not me no I don't
know anybody who crushes and picks it's
mma's a [__] that's why most
professional games don't touch UFC
they're like there's too many ways yeah
it's
it's so it's so volatile I guess I would
still favor Poirier I do worry about the
damage that he's accrued over the years
and what that might do to him but I
don't know he uh you know he's amazing
too uh he is a remarkable fighter and I
think he's just got you know I don't
know if he's the best boxer in the UFC
whatever that means but I put him on the
short list yeah I put him on the short
list for sure he's tremendous so I
probably lean Poirier but it's
to win I'm leaning towards Bud Crawford
I am a little bit worried about the the
I didn't even allude to this when we're
talking about Crawford and Spence the
car crash the eye surgery something to
be aware of when you're talking about
Spence so either way great weekend
you're busy dude I appreciate you making
time man you listen when I need to talk
fight you're my guy so hopefully I'm not
too annoying
no no you're not annoying I'm happy to
make time for you uh so that's quite all
right I appreciate the invite and yeah
um just catch me on uh Fight Night post
fight I'll get you all your suspense and
Crawford results and Analysis from Las
Vegas join me we'll be watching brother
then eventually once you're not so busy
we gotta get you out of here for a
companion man that'd be fun I know I owe
you one I owe you one we'll figure it
out brother you're the best thank you
Luke